what are you most looking forward to the
next two years the next four years
getting done
honestly you know one thing I pride
myself in my history is be able to get
stuff done and not just talk about it
that is a very candid Governor Joe
Lombardo speaking with eight news now
investigator David charns tonight the
governor laying out his plans for Nevada
in his first state of the State address
and we carried his address from Carson
City Live earlier tonight where he
touched on a long list of things that
he'd like to get done eight news now
investigator David charns is live in our
state capitol tonight and David what's
the big takeaway from his proposal
well Governor Lovato promising not to
raise any taxes he also says he wants to
invest in funds to prevent against
emergencies like we saw here the past
couple of years with the pandemic he
wants to increase funding for education
and give parents the option for school
choice
I'm here to say to you tonight our state
of the state is growing stronger every
day
Governor Joe Lombardo laying out his
vision for the future we must remain
dedicated to the twin propositions of
saving for and guarding against
the next unexpected event that shakes
our economy and rattles our livelihoods
the hour-long address a pitch to
lawmakers and the people of Nevada about
moving forward out of the pandemic while
saving for the next emergency
Lombardo says his budget won't raise
taxes but instead makes Nevada even more
attractive for businesses unlocking
Innovation and investments in logistics
entertainment science and technology or
embracing entrepreneurship the message
is that Nevada is ready to partner the
big topic of the night education the
governor says he wants to increase per
student spending by two thousand dollars
provide scholarships to keep teachers in
Nevada and offer parents the option of
choosing a non-public school set aside
politics and turf guarding to deal with
the stubborn facts regarding public
education in Nevada
nevadics public schools have been
historically underfunded and have
historically underperformed for our
children Lombardo also proposed pausing
the state's gas tax for a year giving
state employees raises and immediate
bonuses and creating new laws to hold
career criminals accountable introducing
legislation that makes it harder not
easier to commit a crime in the state of
Nevada
the governor wants to grow the rainy day
fund while creating a new segment of
money for a bipartisan committee to
spend on major infrastructure and
capital projects let's plant the trees
that some of us may never see
and the governor says he wants to do a
lot of those things because he has a
one-year-old grandson who was in at
least part of that uh that address today
before he had to go to bed he also
talked about getting these uh proposals
done with uh Democratic support
obviously he faces some stiff um
hopefully though there won't be too much
uh not there will be some compromise
here but he does face some opposition
from Democrats the word like I mentioned
tonight was compromised we'll just have
to see what happens over the next four
months we're live tonight in Carson City
I'm David charms 8 news now they have a
great job there in Carson City and
Governor Lombardo needs Democratic
support to pass any of his proposals
Democrats control the state senate have
a super majority in the assembly meaning
they do not need a single Republican
vote to pass anything out of that
chamber but each party needs to find a
middle ground to pass anything
Democratic leaders say they are prepared
to work with the governor and tonight
they say there are issues where they can
find common and ground
compensating our state employees
adequately that's a huge issue for
everybody in the state getting the level
of service that that we deserve I would
say that's one obviously we came up with
the people-centered funding formula so
there was a lot of talk about that
tonight but you have to remember that
that was legislative Democrats doing the
hard work of really changing a 50-plus
year Nevada plan that didn't work for
our kids so we're obviously thrilled to
be able to fund education at that level
obviously we need to make sure that we
can fund that we have providers to be in
the schools right I mean money is one
issue but our infrastructure can be
lagging behind but the funding of course
were in favor of we obviously know that
we need to be fiscal responsible but
we're very interested in looking at
could that money be used better
elsewhere right now could we use that
for additional rental relief that's
largely expiring for our people
parents Governor Lombardo did not
mention housing and has addressed
Democrats say his proposals about
changing election related laws they say
are Dead on Arrival